imagine a world where scientists were
the people kids dreamed of becoming
[Music]
where scientific literacy was widespread
and knowledge and experts weren't
mistrusted and stereotyped
most of the problems of the world are
not out of our grasp to fix
in my scientopia the scientific method
is understood and beloved by all
wonder and curiosity are at the heart of
it all backed up by understanding
scientific evidence
as a result no one mistrusts vaccines so
preventable disease is a thing of the
past
medical research is funded better than
hollywood movies leading to
breakthroughs in the cure for cancer
alzheimer's and more
the politicians of the world understand
that climate change must be solved and
don't trade short-term votes for our
long-term future
nations stop squabbling and join
together to explore space
the universe is vast compared to our
tiny blue planet
each speck of light in the sky is a star
like our sun most orbited by their own
tiny planets
billions of galaxies each containing
billions of stars have been mapped
there are a truly unimaginable number of
planets in our universe yet the only one
on which we found life so far is our own
the perspective this gives on the
fragility and unity of earth brings
humanity together like nothing else
the best ideas will come when everyone
has a seat at the scientific table
breakthroughs in social science will
help us to solve the problems of unequal
access to scientific learning and we'll
find ways to cure humanity of prejudice
and discrimination so we can all work
together
and don't think that in scientopia we'll
neglect the importance of music and art
we'll understand what that brings to the
development of creativity and well-being
so crucial to making those breakthroughs
we need
all of this from some scientific
literacy
every child is a natural-born scientist
we just need to work out how all of us
can hang on to that curiosity and wonder
a little bit of childlike science will
take us a long way
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video